patrick dils devra encore faire preuve
de patience il attendra en prison son
procès en révision qui va se dérouler du
20 au 26 juin prochain ses avocats
avaient déposé une demande de mise en
liberté mais la chambre d'instruction de
la cour d'appel de reims s'est déclarée
incompétente aujourd'hui accusé d'un
double meurtre d'enfant il a déjà purgé
14 ans de prison et il ne cesse de
clamer son innocence
à reims clément weill raynal et salah a
gravi lorsqu'ils arrivent au palais de
justice de reims ce matin patrick dils
se doute que sa demande de mise en
liberté a peu de chances d'être acceptée
sur le visage du jeune détenu
on peut lire un très léger sourire
teintée de lassitude
vous savez c'est quelqu'un vous avez
appris à connaître qui est sage et qui
est confiant donc comme il me dit qu'un
certain sens de l'humour dont on peut
chansons pour lequel on peut lui rendre
hommage une décès après 14 ans de
détention sont encore presse à 14 jours
de plus mais pour les avocats des
familles des deux enfants assassinés
patrick dils demeure le principal
suspecte celui qui lorsqu'il avait 17
ans avait avoué le double homicide de
cyril et alexandre avant de se rétracter
pour les parties civiles la présence du
tueur en série francis heaulme sur les
lieux du crime le jour du crime ne
suffit pas à innocenter patrick dils
pour nous rien n'est décidé rien n'est
joué bien évidemment cette révision du
procès n'entraîne absolument pas ni le
sens de patrick dils pour nous ça reste
toujours le coupable
et vous savez que haulmé cité comme
témoin donc simplement comme témoin cet
après midi la cour d'appel de reims a
finalement rejeté la demande de mise en
liberté en se déclarant incompétente
les parents de patrick dils qui luttent
depuis des années pour sa réhabilitation
ont accueilli cette décision avec
philosophie
on n'est pas trop trop déçu parce qu' il
vaut mieux passer christ jusqu'au procès
comme ça fera bien se concentrer sur son
sur la faire et qu'en même temps son
mari sortira que une fois est déplorable
en fille patrick 10 restera donc en
prison jusqu'à son procès qui aura lieu
ici au palais de justice de reims dans
trois semaines
et dans ce procès qui se tiendra devant
une cour d'assises
rien n'est acquis d'avancé patrick dils
deux mains
accusé de l'assassinât de deux enfants
ce sera à lui et à ses avocats de
convaincre les jurés de son innocence